Starks of Winterfell trace their descent
to the first men in the Age of Heroes
families founder was Brandon the Builder
who and the aftermath of the long night
helped establish the Nights Watch legend
has it he enlisted the aid of giants and
the powerful magic of the children of
the forest to raise the mighty wall
which is protected the realm for
generations he went on to build the
ancestral seat of Winterfell and reigned
as the first king in the North the
Starks reigned as kings for thousands of
years even withstanding the invasion of
the Andals as the southern kingdoms fell
and the children of the forest were
driven away the North stood strong
maintaining its religious customs and
its way of life
eventually the reign of the kings of
winter came to an end with the coming of
Aegon the conquerer after Aegon and his
dragons destroyed the combined armies of
the reach in the rock at the field of
fire King torrents stark bent the knee
and swore fealty to the Targaryen
dynasty in order to spare the
destruction of Winterfell
and his people he was forever after
known as the king who knelt as a reward
for his submission Aegon named toran
Lord of Winterfell and warden
of the North the Starks take great pride
in their history and traditions it is
one of the few noble houses that still
keeps the old gods the sacred weirwood
tree limbs large in Winterfell is God's
Word its ancestral sword ice was forged
in ancient Valyria it has been passed
down through the generations House Stark
remains steadfast in its support of the
Nights Watch even as the once
illustrious order has formed on hard
times
much like their sigil the great I Wolf
House Stark is the stuff of legend in
the North and throughout the Seven
Kingdoms and their family words winter
is coming
serve as a reminder of their beginnings
in the wake of the long night and a grim
portent of things to come